thanks everyone for staying on the very
end of the city conflicts so I'm talking
about pseudo random phenomena in finite
fees and so so I'm going to talk about
two results from the last few years that
that showed certain kinds of pseudo
random phenomena in finite fields which
are slightly more algebraic than the
usual than the usual kinds of results
that we see in this area so so so let me
start off by just stating the tooth the
two results that I want to talk about I
won't be able to prove them completely
but i will give some kind of proof
outline of both of them ok good so so
the setting is the following within the
finite field F 2 to the N yeah so
there's a finite field on 2 to the N
elements so just to recap additively
this is this is just F 2 to the N and I
will often be saying F 2 to the N and f
2 to the N and you should know the
difference now multiplicatively this is
this is a cyclic group of order 2 to the
N minus 1 so so this is also an
important fact that we need to remember
and right so so the kind of question
that i'll be looking at is as i'll look
at F 2 to the N and and I will talk
about some objects that come from the
additive world of f 2 to the n then I
also look at takes a multiplicative
objects that come from this cyclic group
and we look at their interaction with
each other and I'm the big headline in
pseudo randomness is that things like
this they don't interact with each other
and that's and the whole goal is to
prove that such a thing happens ok so
good so so I mean much
occasion if you want to define it on top
of F 2 to the N is just there's a
bilinear map which is the multiplication
map which maps f 2 to the n to cross F 2
to the N 2 F 2 to the and so it is and
the multiplication map that comes from
the finite field F 2 to the N is a is a
very special bilinear map it's not
totally I mean it has nice properties
that make it interact well with the
additive group but as when but in many
ways it's still very pseudo-random
relative to to to the editor structure
itself ok so good so let me state the
two kinds of theorems that I'm going to
be showing so the so the first theorem
is it will talk about polynomials in F 2
to the N and they and measure their
correlation with multiplicative
characters of F 2 to the N so so let's
so let me so I'll state it and then i
will i'll explain what all the words and
this mean and so so for a polynomial p
of x 1 up to xn okay so this is an n
variate polynomial over f2 degree of P
at most n to the 0.1 consider the
following quantity that measures the
correlation between P and something so
we look at minus 1 to the P of X where X
varies in F 2 to the N and and then I'll
measure the correlation of that with a
multiplicative character of F 2 3 okay
so and and this is the quantity that I
want to say is small okay where kai is
for example the cubic residue character
of F 2 to the N star and so then I'm
implicitly assuming the 3 divides two to
the N minus 1 so that there is a cubic
residue character ok so so this is the
kind of statement that so first of all
I'm going to say that this is an exhibit
this is this statement exhibit pseudo
randomness in the sense that it's saying
that this object the multiplicative
character does not correlate with this
additive object p of x and so so this is
this is showing that the multiplicative
character is pseudo random relative to
the two polynomials over the final fit
so so so one question that you should
have asked me is what do I mean by P of
X because X is coming from the big
finite field f 2 to the N but so what i
mean is interpret f 2 to the n as f 2 to
the N and plug that X into the
polynomial ok so is there is the
statement of what I'm trying to show
right now clear good and and this and so
right so what's what I find interesting
about this theorem is first of all it's
proof is going to be somewhat
non-standard from the usual way people
prove character some bounds and and and
the quantitative aspect of this theorem
that makes it different from those other
proofs is that it works with volume is
all the way up to degree n to the 0.1
while usual cauchy-schwarz singh methods
would stop it degree around log in how
small is small or small is n to the
minus 0.1 and 0.1 actually stands for
0.01 but ok and and there are similar
statements that one can make about other
objects coming from the multiplicative
word so so another function that you can
put inside here is minus 1 to the trace
of cube root of x so things related to
cube roots in being a perfect cube these
kinds of things do not correlate with
low degree polynomial O
is a squirrel to scope the best of hope
is 2 to the minus epsilon it so it would
have been 1 over square root of two to
the N potentially but this could have
been 2 to the minus epsilon it and if a
statement like and if 2 to the minus
epsilon n is actually true then this
would have amazing consequences in
complexity theory because it would give
an example of a very hard function for
ac0 parity which is a complexity class
which so I'll explain the connection in
a few minutes okay good so this is the
first kind of theorem that I want to
talk about the second kind of theorem
that I want to talk about which taco bar
will be about again so I take an
additive object and I take some other
object related to the multiple to the
multiplicative group and I look at their
interaction and and things will be small
okay so so now the additive object that
i'll take is a sub space over F 2 to the
N so so let a be F 2 B and F to a fine
sub space and dimension of a is okay so
okay so there are specific numbers i
have to write here to make it a theorem
but the point is that it's okay so it's
okay so let me write 0.4 times E and
suppose is not contained in okay so okay
this thing maybe I should state after I
state the theorem so that okay so
suppose something so something has to be
supposed then the expected value over x
varying in a of the following function
minus 1 to the trace of X to the 7 is
small
is less than well sure 82 to the minus
into the episode so so let me make the
statement again so I have an affine
subspace I'm looking at this particular
function place of X to the seven okay i
am measuring how biased it is on the
subspace a and and the question is and
this is saying that this is pretty
balanced it takes the value zero and it
takes the value 1 roughly equally often
but so so why do I need to suppose
something more well okay so so there's
something serious that happens when you
talk about sub spaces which are
dimension less than n over 2 which does
not happen four subspaces of dimension
greater than n over 2 and this is the
issue of the field F 2 to the N having
subfields so the moment f 2 to the N has
a subfield then then if you take a to be
that subfield of them in let's say
subfield of dimension n over to the
moment you take a to be that subfield
then you cannot hope for a statement
like this in general so that yeah so but
so that's exactly what the assumption so
suppose a is not contained in F 2 to the
N over 2 let's say alpha times that plus
beta so whenever a is not contained in a
subfield you have the following you have
this kind of balance pneus property so
so there is the obvious counterexample
to this which is take a to be a subfield
and the moment you omit that sub that
obvious come to example there is indeed
balance as you would expect oh no 2 to
the N over 2 so the munch of f of the
field F 2 to the N the only possible sub
fries are f 2 to the N over 2 or F 2 to
the n over 3 and so on and so so this is
the instance we're dealing with sub
special dimension point for and there's
the possibility that is contained in it
but okay so any questions about what I'm
trying to prove
computer is not conventions oh it oh it
can't contain so if it contains a
subfield then it would have that would
be of size 2 to the n over 3 and then
it's not a problem because you've gone
outside it so if yep so if a was
contained inside this then you raise
that to the power 7 and it stays inside
that and and then the trace of it is
somehow this place is just a linear map
from F 2 to the N 2 F 2 so so this is
like taking the first bit of fear of the
element ok but so the plan for the rest
of the talk is to give an outline of
some lemmas or statements that come
along the way in in the proofs of these
theorems oh good so I will first talk
about the the first theorem so the so
the first thing you do when you see
something like this is you would
probably try to square it and do coffee
Schwartz's several times so so so that
so if you do something like this then
you get a statement of the following
form expected chi of x minus 1 to the V
of X this is at most 2 to the minus n
over 2 to the D this is the kind of
statement that you would get if you took
such a statement you raise it to a
sufficiently large power there's a lot
of Cauchy Schwarz is very carefully and
then at the end you would get some x you
would have to bounce some expression of
the form Chi of X plus ki product or I
for various choices affair and and
statements and expressions of this form
are bounded by the whale bound and and
then and then plugging them black box in
this gives you a statement of this form
which 4d being around login is smaller
is something non trivial but once d
becomes larger than log in its it
doesn't say much ok so the approach that
we take here is actually going to be
quite different is going to be related
to
method from circuit complexity the
rasbora smolenski method proving lower
bounds first arithmetic circuits over f2
so I so I say a few so in this context
thing things can be stripped off and
said without saying too much about
circuits but I do want to say a bit
about it so okay so so the model is so
it's sometimes called a c0 parity and
it's also sometimes called bounded depth
arithmetic circuits over f2 we already
saw arithmetic circuits earlier in the
workshop so this so the model is very
simple you have gates which can do plus
and you have gates that did that can do
time and you have a whole bunch of wires
and all these wires carry elements of f2
okay and then you arrange them in the
circuit and it's bounded depth and its
small set the plus is parity and the
times is multiplication and this is the
exactly the same as what we call a cz
rope arity but so and you can do all by
complementation adding 12 but so so
consider the bounded up there is an
executive or f2 and and then we're
asking the question so let C be depth D
size at most 2 to the N to the 01 / d
then the probability over x lying in F 2
to the n that C of X computes the cue
the the cubic residue symbol of X or
okay maybe I'll give you another the
cube root of x is small oh let me go for
the cube with the cubic resolution
so lambda of X is at most one third plus
n to the minus 0.1 okay where lambda of
X is either one omega omega square
depending on the co set of the perfect
cubes which x lies so lambda max is the
is the function that the cubic residue
symbol it tells you whether it tells you
yeah which co set of the perfect cubes
they set the element X lies in it takes
three different values so what does it
mean for a circuit of this kind to
compute lambda of X well it may be the
circuit has two output wires and it
takes one of three different values
depending on whether lambda of X is zero
Z lambda of X is supposed to be one
Omega Omega square so by compute this
function lambda I don't mean very
anything very deep about complex numbers
anything I'm just it should be able to
distinguish between the three cases of
what lambda of X takes and and and so so
this particular claim is basically
equivalent to this claim that circuits
of depth D and size 2 to the N to the
order 1 over d cannot compute the cubic
residue symbol on more than one-third
plus a small fraction of one-third plus
a little bit fraction of all of F 2 to
the N the and so so getting it with
probability one third is very easy on a
random acts just because I am your one
always or you or you guess something but
yeah but but to get even in a slight
advantage this cannot be done unless you
have very very large circuits ok so this
statement is basically equivalent to
this statement and one can try to prove
with in either language and it turns out
that in some arguments are simpler than
this language and in fact the
step of the proof will be inspired by
things that happen in ac0 parity okay so
so so so one now wants to prove a
statement of this form yeah ah what
happened to the D parameter it so a
polynomial can be computed by depth to
circuit so this statement implies that
without a d I mean plug plug this plug d
equal to 2 into this statement and it
gives you that and if you prove a
statement like that then by the last bro
selenski method of approximations then
it gives you straighten out this form so
so it goes both ways and they need not
be adiabatic and yeah and this degree
being n to the point one has to do with
constant sitting inside this and this so
this would apply no me also sparsity
just this would apply to all polynomials
of sparsity 2 to the n to the zero point
1 year because you can compute them
using such circuits here okay good so
now in order to prove a statement like
this I want to say that detection
suffices to prove a statement which is
which is seemingly much weaker which is
that so for all see as as in as above or
below Billy that's weird as their the
probability over X in F 2 to the N
that's C of X computes lambda of X is
less than zero point nine nine so this
is this formally is I mean proving a
statement like this is formally weaker
than this supposedly but but there's a
trick called random self reduction which
if you can compute it on point 99
fraction of the inputs then you can
actually sorry if you can compute on
one-third plus n to the minus point one
of the inputs then you can actually
computer on point 99 of the inputs and
I'll just explain that in a second but
it's a it's a very neat trick so if
we're given C computing
lambda on 0 1 3rd + n to the minus 0.1
fraction of f 2 to the N then let me
make a circuit see that gets it on point
99 of the inputs and the idea is just to
use the multiplicative Atia of lambda so
so consider the new circuit see tilde
which on input X does the following see
tilled of X is so I just say it in coat
so so compute C of X Y 1 C of X Y to X
times y to the other for several choices
of why I see F X Y n to the epsilon zero
point one way so you have if you have a
circuit that computes it right on
one-third plus n to the minus point when
inputs take that circuit and apply it to
various random shifts of your sink of
your input X look at what see tells you
on all those inputs and because C is
supposed to be computing lambda and
lambda of X Y is supposed to be lambda
of X times lambda of why this should be
telling you something about what see
this should be telling what lambda of X
is so so compute all these things and
take majority all right so it's not take
majority good so compute that divided by
lambda of why I y 1 lambda y 2 and so
that's right but this is a non-uniform
reduction so I just hardwired the wisent
so so I just need to know that there
exists Y eyes and heart and choices for
the lambda y is for which such a
reduction any questions are you yeah if
you do buy you can
of wine then we divide when this x times
y / now it might not be uniform or do
you need you to be uniform do I need it
so the assumption is only a random
element right so it's this better be
uniform right but I don't see why why
should it be uniform I mean you're
dividing again by lambda compute the sea
and then dinner so compute C of X Y I oh
and then divide by lambda Y and even
this has it has a small issue with it
but but it's a tus to find a granularity
for anyone to object probably yeah okay
good so but this is the rough idea huh
I'll tell you anyway okay right so so
they yeah so there are three possible
values for what there are three possible
values for what lambda is it could be
that yeah so but none of them is a
complete majority so there's a little
trick where you instead of taking x
times y I you do X square x y and you do
something I think but but the in
principle this is what what you're
trying to do so compute C on many
different shifts of X so c of x y 1 x c
of x y 2 etcetera this is supposed to be
lambda of X if C indeed work correctly
and so and then take majority or
plurality or something okay and and this
is something that can be done by a
simple circuit because you don't have
you have only n to the zero point one
such values which you want to take
majority of ok but so we're now reduced
ourselves to situation which is like
this we want to show just a very very
weak average case lower bound on the
computation of lambda by arithmetic
circuit sewers yeah bye-bye arithmetic
circuits over f2 okay so yeah so so for
this way
randomized reduction is already an
obstacle if you want to prove an
exponentially small cordless this
randomized election is the obstacle in
fact for proving x-ray a few controls a
resident % bound for [ __ ] weights that
are a majority get on top and then I is
it 02 then you could run the reduction
with an exponential number of wise right
that by an exponential number doesn't
the size grew up a so if you produce a
ninety-nine percent correlation for [ __ ]
visit our easy zero parity but I don't
know Jahi get on top it comes as one
right but there are certainly boots
right but all those sees you can invoke
from the other circle so this is one
copy of C app now there are two to the N
to the epsilon copies of see justice
eyes to the size is really large
rightful to stick to that to that city
okay okay so now we need to prove you
know a normal lower bond without without
any emphasis on the probability of
success just point 99 probably okay good
so now I'll so i will give a very very
high level sequence of observations that
is that motivate how one proves the
lower bound of such a kind so this is
really what happens behind the scenes in
the rustboro Smolinski circuit lower
bound method but but I say it and very
very very high level stuff okay so I
make an observation
not all functions have low complexity
for whatever complete complexity me
that's hard to argue it okay oh yeah but
so so now I make a definition I say a
function is versatile if with itself you
can compute all functions f is versatile
if with F can compute all functions okay
easily
so that's the definition that's a hard
or giveth okay so I'll put these two
together and I will make make the main
observation that will give us a proof
that so function if a function is
versatile it cannot have low complexity
because we did then using it you would
be able to compute all functions easily
and then but all functions you don't
have a low complexity so versatile
functions have hiked on
okay and and so the final step is a
lemma that lambda of X is versatile in
some sense I have to make everything for
me and at this point we have a little
lambda cannot be computed easy it has no
it does not have low context okay so so
I will end by giving you the statement
it is this part of the talk by giving
you the statement of what does it mean
that lambda is versatile and then press
0 so this is lambda is versatile okay
and this is just this is going to be
proper cleanly stated statement and like
this argument over here so so here
here's what the claim is so for all
functions f from F 2 to the N 2 F 2 to
the N I can use lambda to compute F
easily so this is what I mean by it so
there exist functions GNH from F 2 to
the N 2 F 2 to the N of f 2 degree
there's something I have to define them
at most n over 2 such that F is equal to
G times lambda plus it so
so is the statement of the screen for
every function f there are two functions
G H of low degree in some sense so this
F 2 degree is not your usual notion of
degree but it's some kind of low low
complexity in s measure such that that
function f can be written easily it can
be computed easily using lambda ok so
all i need to say now is what the f 2
degree means and then i have to correct
the statement to be actually true so ft
degree is of a function of a function G
from F 2 to the N 2 F 2 to the N is the
maximum degree so what do we do so i'm
going to write f 2 to the N as f 2 to
the N all right f this other f 2 to the
N also as f2 to the end that's just
choosing a basis then this G becomes a
collection of maps n maps from F 2 to
the N 2 F 2 to the N I should it becomes
a collection g1 up to GN from here to
here and and it's the maximum degree of
GI each di is a map into F took that's
it right so then right GI as an element
of f 2 x 10 correction you write it
uniquely as a low degree polynomial or
f2 and take it the maximum degree of GI
over all over all the eyes and that is
what is the f2 degree of the function G
and it's easy to see actually that this
is independent of how you choose basis
in it in in all these choices ok so it
is a well-defined notion for functions
independent of how you defined all these
bases so so the maximum that the f2
degree of a function can be is n having
f2 degree n over 2 is remarkably you
know it's a low-complexity property so
the statement is every function f can be
written with the help of these low
complexity things GNA
this way and what sources this is not
exactly correct so so one way to fix it
is that most functions can be written
like this another way to fix it is so
but then there's also some E and E is
eli's and some low dimensional space
which and we don't even need to know how
low the dimension is so the fact that
it's coming from a low dimensional space
I mean is is the sufficiently good
statement of versatility so so with a
statement like this along with ideas
from the raspberry selenski method one
can one can show that the function
lambda cannot be approximated by law
degree polymers cannot be computed by
small arithmetic circuits and we get a
stiffener of that form that lambda
cannot be computed by arithmetic
circuits on point 99 fraction of the
inputs and then that fed into the random
self reduction it gives us a final one
okay so good is there any questions
about the statement ok and so answer let
me also let me also also state the the
main lemma that goes into that llama
which so it's just a curious it's a
curious average of combinatorial lemma
that I mean I've never seen a question
like this before I don't think I'd ever
see one like this again it just happened
to be the question that needed to be
studied so so here is the the world you
have Z 2 to the N minus 1 and so let em
sitting inside Z 2 to the N minus 1 be
integers with
base to Hamming weight so the meaning
you write it in base 2 and look at its
Hamming weight at most n over 2 so the
size of em is about half of Z 2 to the N
minus 1 okay now consider alpha sitting
inside Z 2 to the N minus 1 alpha being
one third so one-third is an element of
Z 2 to the N minus 1 let's Italy does
not divide two to the image 1 so
one-third is an element of it it
actually looks like 10 10 10 let's is
another this is how it looks in basic be
in base 2 okay then then the claim is
the following the size of em Union M
plus alpha is what what do you think the
size of em union of the self I babies
half use em has size half of 2 to the N
that's it M plus alpha is you take that
set then you add to it this particular
number so they should be small addition
is more 2 to the N minus 1 like in Z to
change we should be school to Greek one
no no no it's the integer addition mod 2
to the N minus 1 that's what makes it
yeah well well April so my first guess
was well they are nothing to do with
each other so by three-fourths I think
that's a pretty good guess so it's not
it's it's so in for this particular
alpha at some point 8 37 okay so it's
it's no rational numbers I know point 8
3 times 2 to the N and right and so the
basic question and the basic yeah so and
then the lemma that one needed was this
is at least half plus epsilon and 2 to
the N and the same thing holds for any
periodic number if you take any any
integer here which is basically a
rational with small denominator plus if
you do sir it's actually Moses recall
it's more than three quarters for that
particular number but for other numbers
it's less than three quarters and it
it has its own there's a whole world of
numbers of it all right so but for
action is a small denominator where the
denominator is not one this size is
always at least half plus epsilon times
due to be it and somehow this is exactly
what gives you the versatility o people
so that's what I say for this first
statement yeah so so I don't have so
much time I disraeli so so so let me say
very briefly a few things about the
second statement this was the fact that
some functions like 36 to the 7th vary
by unbiased when you restrict them to
low dimensional sub spaces provided the
provided there is no subfield lying it
out so the usual way one proof
statements of this form is through the
sum-product theorem which which is the
number one theorem for proving things in
the absence of subfields so so somehow
this proof that that are this time that
I'm talking about so this actually joint
work with Eddie Benzes on this time that
I'm talking about now uses the absence
of subfields in a very roundabout way
which yeah so it's still puzzling to me
as to why even weren't so so here is
what the statement so let a be sitting
inside f 2 to the N it's a nap a fine
space so so first of all look at the
polynomial product over all alpha and a
X minus alpha again let's call this p
sub a of X so it's a elementary fact
that this is actually of the form i
going from 0 to dimension a a I X to the
two to the I there are very very few
monomials that show up in this product
only dimension a many of them and and in
fact PA of X is a linear polymer it's
additive ok so it also turns out that
there is there is a polynomial Q a of X
such that the image of QA
is equal to it so so this was a
polynomial which was a linear
transformation in fact who's Colonel was
the setting the Spacey now I'm giving
you a linear transformation whose image
is the spacing and its degree will also
be as low as possible given this
constraint with QA of X equal to some I
going from 0 to n minus dimension of a
of bi x to the tutorial so there is an
additive polynomial of as low degree as
you could hope whose image is a and and
these these people these polynomials are
quite related teacher this call the
colonel subspace for now it is called
the image subspace penomet and good so
so so i won't go into the proof of
theorem maybe i want you to say how
anything fits it but i'll give you the
statement of the lemma that detects the
absence of subphase this is always the
Turkish part of a proof of what what
step of your proof is going to take
advantage of the fact that a does is not
lying inside the inside a sub fee so I
make that I'll make just that statement
but so QA of X is its b0 plus b1 sorry
be 0x plus b1 x square plus up to be n
minus dimension a ok let me call that d
e
n minus D X to the 2 to the N minus D
but this is how QA of X looks so so here
is the the main llama about subfields if
he is not contained in alpha times first
yes so f2 to the J plus beta for all J
so if he is not contained inside an
affine shift of a sub strict subfield
then you cannot have too many you cannot
have a long run of zeros in the
coefficients of queuing then in every I
sitting inside zero up to n minus D with
sighs I at least d minus one there
exists some I and I with bi not equal to
0 so this is the image subspace of
polynomial of the subspace a it has some
coefficients but why why does this
polynomial exist I don't know no I do
but so if that's relevant for this
statement it has some sample some
coefficients this these coefficients
cannot have too many zeros amongst them
in this particular sense there is no
long run of consecutive zeros in the
coefficient and right answer so this is
the statement this that it's it's it
exactly detects when a is contained
inside sub free if a if a is if a is
contained inside an affine shift of a
sub grade then you will see such a
sequence of zeros if it is not contained
then you do not see such a sequence of
zeros and and thus yeah and so this
llama enables you to distinguish
during the presence of a subfield in the
absence of a subfield the in relation to
a yeah so in one line how does QA of X
show up in the statement that in the
statement that trace X to the seven is
unbiased on on the subspace a so so so
here is what the picture is so we have f
2 to the N this is a big space we're
looking at the map the map i was looking
at first race of x2 the seven so there's
this initial map it's sends x two x to
the seventh then there's another map
which maps it down to f/2 which is the
trace map and a sit somewhere here and i
want to show that on a the composition
of these two maps gives you some kind of
balanced function so what we introduced
into this is then you field f 2 to the N
and and this is the map QA remember the
image of QA is is a so so we have the
map QA mapping all the way to way then
we compositional composes and so this
this so we want to say the net
composition of all these maps when
mapping from F 2 to the N all the way to
f2 is non constant and it son it's
unbalanced and in particular it's not
concept so so the kind of polynomial
that you need to analyze is Trace no QA
of x to the q of x to the 7th and you
want to understand its behavior on the
field f 2 to the N so you take this
polynomial mod X to the two to the N
minus X and and if you can show that
this particular polynomial has a nonzero
coefficient that already means that this
polynomial is non constant and and once
you have there is none constant then
there are the ways of showing that son
bias so so I won't mention that but how
do you show that this polynomial has a
nonzero coefficient whether you open it
up and look at all the coefficients that
you get
it's a big mess and if so an input in so
by default you wouldn't hope to be able
to prove anything about it but but
somewhere you won't show there's
something as a nonzero coefficient and
and the lemma that comes in to save you
is is this particular thing it tells you
that there aren't too many zero
coefficients lying around in some in
some sense and and this number
fortunately uses the absence of sub
print so yeah so it gives you exactly
the kind of state module but so that's
all I'm going to say about this any
questions so this is an appendix
tactless yeah what if there is a subway
oh well then what happens oh so you
choose n to be a prime and then it gives
you an F in your sector yeah so there
are no subjects face follow the larger
of dimension command over ah wait so do
you zoom to the devil ah thanks all
right well so this so I so I mean you
open it up it I told you it's a big mess
so I mean so in order for the mess not
be too big you're showing at a speed
other questions and this is